so I am fascinated by medium so can you
each tell me something you learned about
that skill or that profession that just
blew your mind totally surprised you you
need Febreze inside the crystal ball
that's what I learned that's the thing
I needed to learn sorry
I learned ocean fresh the one the ocean
fresh one sorry
I learned that it's really important to
listen to your first thought
oh great answer and when if you're if
you're doing a reading or something like
that or even just in communication in
general whatever that first thought is
that's the right one and if you're
doubting that that's the devil that
ain't no good that's fake news it feels
like a good life lesson yeah well it
works I like that
um another thing I like from our
production no it's Tiffany there was a
great quote from Justin about you he was
talking basically about how you you
basically nail everything you do
everything you do Works he said whether
she's flubbing a line or she's saying
something that's Off Script or doing
something you don't expect it's always
perfect authentic and real so I want an
example of a Time on set when you
thought you flubbed something but found
some unexpected magic in it and now we
can see in the Final Cut okay so there's
a part where
um Harriet comes back to the house and
uh the script said something completely
different than what I ended up in the
movie so I'm talking to Owen's character
and and I'm going off on him and in the
script it says that I'm just like I
can't believe you would do this why
would you do this to somebody and I
decided to say yo mama would be ashamed
of you I can't believe like first go off
on her like talking about his mom and
stuff and when it and I was like oh I'm
sorry guys I just felt like you know he
was like no no go ahead try it again and
you know then I did the lines and then
they gave me one more chance and then I
talked about his mama again and his
Grandmama and his ancestors and
everybody and that's in the movie A lot
of things Pitch Perfect you nail it so
much all right Jamie for you so we get a
little line about this in the film The
idea of what it's like for her living in
the crystal ball but now I need to know
more about it so what do you think the
day today is like for Madame Leota in
the crystal ball what does she do during
her down time I think she's watching
real housewares of all of the Cities
you know Beverly Hills New York uh
Atlanta I think she's binging I think
she's a bit of a Binger because it's you
know
I mean I I'm fine on my own for a minute
but you know she's in there for a
hundred years it's it's yeah I think
it's reality TV is you don't think you
can play in Spades no no I just picture
her now watching reality TV in a very
like fresh lovely smelling crystal ball
I feel like that's all she needs yes
that's all she needs a bigger broader
question for both of you because you
both have filmographies that are down to
the floor but there are so many mine is
longer because I'm older and now your
filmography includes an Oscar win yes it
does I will say and celebrate that every
opportunity I get what is something you
both do in this movie that made even you
think like damn I've never done this
before and now I have a new tool in my
acting toolkit so to speak I wanted a
lot of my stats I did a lot but I've
done my own stunts before but I have
never rode on a barrel
in the sky on a harness and then right
right I could picture that never done
that before
um I've never done motion capture
so
um I I had to learn
a lot of dialogue and then have a hand
like a neck brace holding my head still
and a a ton of dots on my face to to
capture my Expressions which then they
animate and I didn't I've never I've
never done any sort of motion capture
stuff at all and you ever done that
three you did the 360 camera I did the
360. I've never had so many cameras
taking a picture of me at one time and I
gotta do like this I've done I've done
also you know obviously green screen
blue screen I've done that work before
so that wasn't new but I'd never done
um the motion capture I didn't have to
wear the suit by the way whenever I see
whenever I see
um uh Avid the behind the scenes of
Avatar
and the emotional work that these people
are doing and they're just wearing suits
with cameras all over them it's
astonishing to me technology that
fascinates me it's fascinating a bit on
every level and the visual effects level
and also the performance the performance
but see the visual effects level is all
technology and once you know how to do
that it's science
the Performing part is not science which
is why AI will never work really because
that is emotions are real and they come
from human beings they don't come from
machines and so to watch beautiful
actors do that kind of work under those
circumstances is is is something very uh
impressive to me I also became an
understudy of the the ad I was ad 1.5 uh
so when they would say cut I'd be like
all right first team out second team in
bringing the Spheres spheres bring them
in bring balls in and they'll do balls a
lot of balls a lot of balls I've done
movies with balls now and not just those
yeah they do the still they hold the
silver sphere this ball and then they
hold this color card next to it and then
they like stand around they gotta kind
of do it it's cool I will say no matter
what your craft is it cannot be replaced
by technology so every single Department
in this industry that should be out the
window not an option personal questions
inspired by the movie I love the idea of
a ghost wink and I'm convinced that they
really happen so have you either of you
ever experienced a ghost swing and if so
what have happened when my grandma
passed the way last year my friend told
me that my grandma would reach out to me
every time I saw a white feather that
that would be her saying that she's
there for me right so like maybe a few
days later I'm uh in my house I come out
my bedroom and I walk into the living
room there are feathers everywhere
there's a dead bird in the middle of the
floor and my cat's in there like hey
would you like it and I was like Grandma
else you wouldn't want me to do this so
y'all ask Grandma do not come to me like
this anymore I do not like this and so
she's been showing up in my dreams ever
since every night I think a ghost wink
is every time I look at my dog
every time he looks at me and really
looks at me I feel like some like all of
the sort of people I've Loved are
looking back at me and and I'm a little
as my people will all tell you I'm a
little obsessed with my dog but I I
truly do you know because you look at
each other but then when you really lock
in I feel like I'm getting a message
from
um people that I love that that they're
right there and that they're with me
beautiful example mine is a red bird in
my backyard which I'm convinced is my my
papi
okay this necklace is really everything
beautiful one of the highest compliments
I could get today I cherish this thing
non-stop thank you both for your time
today